[Musique]
quand j'ai vu le titre du projet qui
s'appelle des cercles immense je me suis
dit ça c'est un projet génial pas pour
ce qui concerne claude nicolas ledoux
c'était peut-être pas simplement un rêve
mais plus un projet je vaux transition
ne convient plus aux pass d'accès quand
il n'imagine pas des jardins aux quatre
coins du monde c'est là qu'il est qu'il
vit qu'il écrit et qu'il observe le
jardin de gilles clément
c'est sa balle est dans la creuse c'est
ça que j'adore c'est quand on change
aussi bien au niveau de la strate
herbacée que les arbustes sa chance à
ben on peut essayer ne se sera relevé
on fait après avoir redessiné par avant
je venais ici quand j'avais une
quinzaine mais même avant me balader
depuis la maison de mes parents qui est
à environ 500 mètres peu plus peut-être
pour aller dans la vallée où ian jardin
et d'aujourd'hui on vient parce que
c'était un endroit où il y avait des
insectes pour voyez bien avant
ce que ce qu'on voit sur le plateau là
nous sommes sur le plateau parce que tu
à l'abri du vent
non
[Musique]
depuis qu'il s'est installé dans cette
vallée peuple et d'insectes qui le
faisait rêver
le jardinier à fait cohabiter des
plantes venues du froid ou d'amérique
latine et les a laissés vivre avec les
autochtones son jardin au mouvement est
aussi un jardin planétaire c'est grande
berce qu'il affectionne en sont la
parfaite illustration
c'est une plante originaire du caucase
une région du monde où il y avait avant
la dernière glaciation nous avions ces
plantes là elle était chez nous elles
sont restés un petit peu plus disant
protéger parle du froid extrême à cause
des deux maires qui sont à côté de ces
massifs montagneux et la flore qui hélas
est une fleur à ses anciennes les
grandes bears en font partie ben allal
revient chez nous était peut-être la
meilleure c'est un rien n'est figé
jamais et l'homme s'il intervient ne le
fais surtout pas pour détruire c'est ce
que gilles clément enseigne depuis
toujours aux étudiants qui l'interrogent
c'est d'ailleurs avec l'un de ses
anciens élèves qu'ils portent le projet
du cercle immense d'arc et senans
quand j'étais étudiant s'est déjà
quelqu'un qui me passionnait parce que
oui c'est un des seuls paysagiste qui
est écrit sur le métier du jardinier du
paysage et donc que j'ai eu de la chance
de l'avoir comme enseignant ensuite à
l'école de versailles
et comme directeur de diplômes et puis
on a gardé un lien d'amitié pendant 20
ans et quand j'ai vu ce projet sortir le
projet du cercle immense imaginé le
projet dessiné par le doux j'ai dit
voilà ça c'est le projet que qu'on doit
faire exil clément
est ce que vincent tu as dit qu'on a
découvert avec le géomètre qui participe
aux travaux que le doubs c'était un
petit peu trompé sur l'alignement de son
bâtiment des écuries canon il est décalé
de 26 cm alors m
c'est le seul bâtiment qui est pas ligne
et tout le reste des bâtiments la saline
nickel mais finalement le petit dernier
les écuries décalage faut tout détruire
non mais on s'est posé des questions des
questions fondamentales essayer de faire
jouer la garantie à ce stade du projet
la forme est donné bordures et chemine
sont en place reste à planter les 400
arbres du pourtour et à préparer les
futurs jardins et comme l'idée c'est de
faire un laboratoire
on sait que c'est un jardin qui sera
jamais figé c'est ça aussi c'est sur ce
paradoxe entre un projet qui peut
paraître formelle mais en fait on donne
le droit de tester des choses et donc si
c'est un laboratoire et bien il a
beaucoup d'années devant lui dans 200
ans on fera autre chose mais la
structure sera peut être la même et
cette année les étudiants jardiniers
paysagistes se sont bousculés pour
proposer des projets inspirés des
concepts de gilles clément leur jardin
seront ceux du premier festival
au delà du mur
[Musique]